good evening we do start tonight with
new developments in a deadly downtown
motel fire thanks for joining us here at
six o'clock i'm denise faldis and i'm
brian loftis six people died in the
alpine motel fire more than seven months
ago now the owner
and manager are facing charges sasha
loftis has more
these charges come nearly eight months
since the devastating fire here at the
alpine motel downtown
d.a wolfson says that he hopes this can
bring justice and
closure to victims families and the
victims who survived this
the fire was just days before christmas
you'll remember on december 21
2019 six died and many others were hurt
now the owner of the motel adolfo or
oscar garcia
and co-owner and manager melinda meyer
each face
six charges of involuntary manslaughter
and 15
counts of performance of an actor
neglect of duty
in disregard of safety resulting in
substantial bodily harm or death
the district attorney says that they
intentionally disregarded proper
maintenance of fire alarms
fire exits and the heating system and
that led to those deaths
d.a wolfson says he is working to set a
precedent for the future here
i want justice in this case whatever
that
is so i want the families of the victims
and the surviving victims to know
that we're bringing this case forward so
that the victims can have their day in
court
so that hopefully justice will be served
the motel owner mr orozco garcia is also
charged with four
counts of dissuading a witness or victim
in reporting a crime
all d.a wolfson would say is that orozco
garcia used a gun to
intimidate a witness now if both orozco
garcia and his associate are
charged here they could each face
substantial prison time
we also asked d.a wolfson why it took so
long to bring these charges
he said this was a very complicated case
and his team
wanted to be as thorough as possible
reporting downtown sasha loftis
8 news now